/ quant à la mère de zacarias moussaoui
elle souhaite qu'il puisse purger sa
peine en france c'est aussi le souhait
de ceux qui étaient ses amis mais cela
paraît très improbable réactions
recueillies par amaury guibert frédéric
basket avec notre bureau à montpellier
son enfant échappe à la mort mais elle
refuse de parler de victoire ou de
soulagement pour la mère de zacarias
moussaoui la peine de prison à vie
infligée à son fils ne change rien c'est
pareil notre compagnie avis aux
condamnés à mort condamné à mort vous
savez monsieur moi je m'en mords et je
vois aussi on meurt une voix m condamné
à vie et la mort à pittsburgh je me sens
une partie de moi qu'il est morte
intérêts avec mon fils qui va être
enterré toute sa vie à 37,1 pour des
choses qui l'a pas fait
je souhaitais que la preuve dit ceux
sortis sans français qui soit jugé pour
les faits pour qu'est ce qui la fait pas
pour qui ce qu'il a dit gilles cohen et
fabrice guillon sont des amis d'enfance
de zacarias moussaoui persuadé d'avoir
influencé le jury lorsqu'ils ont
témoigné en sa faveur au procès ils ont
alors décrit un homme bien différent de
celui qui occupait le box des accusés
évitez le neubourg c'était déjà le but
premier et puis et puis bon ensuite on
verra en sait pas ce qui va se passer
mais déjà très content oui de lyon
d'avoir pu lui faire échapper un associé
j'ai l'impression qu'on a peut-être
sauvé un peu malgré lui et c'est pas une
mauvaise chose mais en même temps il ya
beaucoup d'amertume de voir que il ya
une sanction aussi lourde pour
finalement ce qu'ils ne savent hâte que
des paroles puisque aucun fait n'a été
prouvée
la mère de zacarias moussaoui espère
maintenant que son fils pourra purger sa
peine en france
mais les chances que cela se réalise
sont quasi nulles alors elle aimerait au
moins pouvoir lui rendre visite dans sa
prison américaine